Une vingtaine de pent avec impa,
vendredi matin au Yacht Club
de Québec, l'arrivée du voilier
nommé Caractère, avec à son bord
la familJEAN LEGJEAN LEGJEAN LET
- Écoute, d'avoir vu tous
nos amis, nos proches.
C'est vraiment les bonnes
émotionsJULIE SAVARD
- Aujourd'hui, on ne réalise
pas vraiment l'ampleur
de ce qu'on a vécu.
à bord du navire de douze mètres
et demi que la famille a dor
mangé et fait l'école à la
maison. Elle a parcouru plus
davantage que le tour de
la Terre.
- On avance à une moyenne
d'environ neuf kilomètres heure,
de navigation.
- Durant leur péri
les Savard-Legault ont amarré
leur voilier dans une vingtaine
- On avait ce projet de vie-là
de partier pendant
quatre ans et on est tellement
content de... On est tellement
ce qu'on a réalisé.
- Si vivre la pandre la pandre a
été un moindre mal, il y a
parfois eu aussi des momentsliee
Savard apprend que son père
d'un grave cancer, alors
que le voilier se trouve à des
milliers de kilomètres du
la maladie d'un proche, puisil s
tard. Alors il a fallu que
je revienne au Québec avecsemen,
je l'ai vu. J'ai pu le voir
la veille de son décès et on est
resté quelques mois. Les filles
et moi au Québec, pendant
que Jean, lui, était resté
en Polynésie
- Puis, en mai dernier, en
pleine nuit, à plus de 300 000
nautiques au large entre
le Panama et les îles Caïman,
le voilier a perdu son mât.
Le trajer s'est do
fait à l'aide du moteur
du bateau, plutôt qu'avec
les voiles.
- Finalement, ça a bien étéparce
blessé, mais c'est un moment
qui aurait pu être très,
- Mais pour Julie et Jean,les ds
n'auront pas réussi à ternir la
riche expérience familiale vécue
- Je pense que ça va les marquer
pour le reste de leurs jours.
- De retour à Québec, le couple
s'est déjà trouvé un nouvel
emploi et leurs enfants ont
et d'aller à l'école.
- On s'attend à ce que les
montagnes russes d'émotions,
mais on le voit de façon
On a des projets. On est
contents de revenir au Québe
On aimait notre vie ici avant,
donc la vie reprend ici pour
- Bien qu'elle ne prévoit passe,
la famille Savard-Legault compte
la terre ferme pour quelquesann.
Ici, Louis-Philippe Arsenau